hi there this is Steve Kaufman founder
of Lync continuing my series of seven
secrets to successful language learning
you'll remember the first one was to
spend the time the second one was to do
the things that you like to do in
language learning the third one was to
develop and improve your ability to
notice what's happening in the language
now the fourth one is focus on words
words vocabulary is much more important
than grammar and in fact if you learn
words if you have lots of words and if
you learn these words naturally through
lots of listening and reading the
grammar will eventually fall into place
nothing prevents you from occasionally
reviewing grammar rules in a small
grammar book it's probably a good thing
to do I do it but my major emphasis is
accumulating words and that's why I
blink are number 1 measurable is how
many words do you know no some people
say that the emphasis should be on
learning chunks of words in the form of
phrases that we can easily reproduce and
certainly this is a good thing to do but
the phrases themselves consist of words
so you still have to know what words
mean and the words you can't learn them
in isolation you have to learn them from
meaningful content and that's why again
at link when you save a word when I save
a word to a date my personal database at
link not only do I capture all the
phrases where that word occurs but the
next time that word appears in any new
text link it'll be highlighted in yellow
and so I'm constantly working to
increase my known words total at link
grammar which is nothing other than a
description of correct usage is
something that develops gradually if you
try to memorize the rules of grammar and
even if you were able to learn the rules
which I think is
very difficult to do without a
sufficient amount of the input but even
if you learned the rules if you didn't
have enough of a vocabulary to follow a
conversation in a particular area or to
express express your ideas then you
would not be able to say very much on
the other hand if you have a large
vocabulary you will be surprised and how
gradually and especially if you you've
seen these words in different phrases
you'll start to notice how naturally you
start to speak with the words in the
correct order and in the correct form so
once again focus your efforts on words
and there are a number of strategies
that can help you some people like to
use flashcards and there's Anki and
supermemo and other such methods out
there my own preference is to do a lot
of listening and reading and I will
focus my listening and reading and as I
said in a previous video I will all as
much as possible try to read what I'm
listening to and listen to what I'm
reading but I will also focus on one
author at a particular during a
particular period or on one subject area
which might be politics or history or
economics and what this does it ensures
that a certain range of words appear
more frequently so that because I'm
staying with one author Polestar for
example in Russian then I become
familiar with his vocabulary or if I am
listening to current events interviews
and I become very familiar with that
vocabulary and so occasionally I'll
change my emphasis change the author
change the subject area but always try
to focus for a certain period of time on
one particular area so that I get enough
repetition so that I can accumulate my
vocabulary so there you have it the
secret number four focus on words and
the rest of it will fall into place
thank you for listening